and the only diploma I have in my office
is the Dale Carnegie diploma but the
Dale Carnegie is up there because that
changed my life
I probably read five to six hours a day
I don't read as fast now as when I was
younger he said because you weren't you
or she didn't hire you is that right
that's true he's and I I was ready to
convert believe me what some believe
nation it seven my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent adds
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and make a difference in this
world using it now I started the belief
life series to tackle different topics
outside of just practical hands-on how
to run a business and so to help you
live your best believe life today we're
gonna learn ten mind-blowing facts about
Warren Buffett enjoy
[Music]
fact number one he bought his first
stock at age eleven I bought my first
stock in the spring of 1942 was 11 and
if you remember you don't remember no
one watching this will remember but but
we were losing the war at that time and
we were getting we were we were getting
totally creamed in the South Pacific and
the Philippines felt when the death
march at Bataan and all that sort of
thing it was not until the Battle of
Midway which was a little later the
things started turning around what I was
optimistic on the country then and I've
been optimistic on the country ever
since and incidentally the Dow Jones
average then was 100 and at 17,000 it's
no one has ever been a success betting
against America since 1776 and they're
not gonna be a success in the future
doing it either fact number two when he
was a teenager he was already making
more money than his teachers by doing
his newspaper delivery route Buffett
says from delivering papers he learned
the importance of hard work and
reliability
I also learned frankly that that if you
did a good job you were you were gonna
yeah you were gonna move up I mean had
the very fact that I did a good job in
Spring Valley got me the Westchester
routes later on I'm getting the five
building Westchester complex home to
Washington's elite transformed a job
into a business by the time World War
two ended Buffett not yet fifteen had
saved what an average American earned in
a year I was fortunate in that I was
here during probably the most
interesting period you could be in
Washington during World War two I mean I
I delivered the papers when Roosevelt
died and when the atomic bomb was
dropped
newspapers remain close to Buffett's
heart he owned several and a newspaper
tossing contest is a regular event at
his Berkshire Hathaway annual meetings
you know me I still like to deliver
papers if anybody's got a lump of paper
out out there I'll be glad fact number
three he was rejected by Harvard
Business School so when you graduated
from university abrasca you applied to
Harvard Business School and were
rejected that's true
has Harvard ever announced that they've
regretted that this woman I understand
the development officer is kind of
unhappy fact number four his idol
refused to hire him the first time he
applied rejected by Harvard you went to
Columbia Business School and then you
met the man who you really idolized Ben
Graham when you graduated you wanted to
go work for him and his firm and then he
rejected you for an interesting reason
in those days I understand that they
were Jewish firms and non Jewish firms
and his was a Jewish firm and you
weren't Jewish so he said because you
weren't Jewish he didn't hire you is
that right that's true he's and I I was
ready to convert believe me up I think
they might have fellows a little phony
of the time something I but it was it
was true that there were very few firms
in Wall Street that would hire Jews at
that time and then only employed five or
six people but he told me that they sent
that they had were able to employ five
or six people they really felt that the
Jews could not get into most jobs in
Wall Street and that they were gonna get
employ only Jews fact number five
he spent $100 on a Dale Carnegie course
to improve his speaking I'd first signed
up for a Dale Carnegie course in
Manhattan when I was at Columbia but I
gave him a check and I stopped paying
the check the gutless wonder so when I
got out here and now I'm selling stocks
I realize I just had to be able to do it
so I I went and took $100 of cash and
handed it to Walter Keane is that the
Dale Carnegie course and and and we did
all these crazy things and like what
what did you do oh you know standing on
tables and talking I mean there were 30
of us there that couldn't say our own
name with
choking up and being in the company of
them and wally was a great teacher and
he did these things to get out of
ourselves I mean you know so that we
just weren't all tangled up you know and
with fear of failure and all that sort
of thing and then as soon as I finished
it I went right out to the University
with them what was then called the
University of Mama ha I said I want to
start teaching and so I started teaching
when I was 21 because I knew I had to
get up in front of me doing this or I'd
go back and the only diploma I have in
my office is the Dale Carnegie diploma
I'm I'm proud of the ones from
University but I know where they are but
the Dale Carnegie is up there because
that changed my life in a very big way
now you can't stop me talking of me
fact number six he spends up to 80% of
his day reading how do you keep up with
all the media and information that goes
on in our crazy world and in your world
of Berkshire Hathaway what's your media
routine I just read and read and read I
probably read five to six hours a day I
don't read as fast now as when I was
younger but I read five daily newspapers
I read a fair number of magazines I read
10 Kay's I read annual reports and I
read a lot of other things too this I i
I've always enjoyed reading I love
reading biographies for example hint doc
number seven
he drinks an alarming amount of Coca
Cola each day I drink probably 512 ounce
cokes a day and that's about 700
calories and I've been doing it more or
less all my life I can't imagine anybody
that feels better than I do I mean I'm
happy I enjoy life you know and I've
always wondered if I had a twin and he
had to eat broccoli and asparagus and
Brussels sprouts and done it every day
and I'd been drinking my cold and eating
potato chips and there are some cookies
that also you know have a hundred
calories per ounce the you know which of
us
III think the other guy would be gone I
mean I think he probably would have
committed suicide and he certainly
wouldn't feel as good about life as I
feel good every day fact number eight
people are so fascinated with him that
they'll spend millions of dollars just
to have lunch
with him Warren Buffett is a very unique
and very special guy and he is a
charitable person one of the charities
that he notes money to is Glide and it
is in San Francisco
he offered going back about ten years to
have lunch with anyone that would pay
for it so he auctioned himself off and
he raised I believe $25,000 to have
lunch with Warren Buffett I heard about
it got his phone number by the way that
took at least a year to get his phone
number because I didn't want to just
call up the company but I did get his
phone number and when I called him he
actually answered the phone himself he
said hi this is Warren and I was sort of
stumped for words I couldn't quite
believe that I had Warren Buffett on the
telephone and I said Warren this is
Allen Stillman I own some restaurants
called Smith and I never got to say the
last word he said and Wilensky I said
that's correct how do you know he says
all I come into a couple of your
restaurants I said really I have an idea
he said what's that I said I want to
donate an additional and I don't
remember exactly the number but I think
was $25,000 for you to come to New York
and have lunch at Smith lamanski
and I'm going to give to your favorite
charity glide $25,000 it took him about
maybe five seconds to say you mr.
Stillman had the deal you put it
together and I'll be there well the
first time that he did that
it went for a million dollars and since
that time it's gone for two and a half
of three million dollars so that
currently he does it once a year he
comes to Smith olenski has lunch and I
suspect that this year won't be any
different it's going to go for two and a
half or three million dollars you can
bring six or seven friends and Warren
himself will absolutely have lunch with
you and you can ask him anything you
want unless it be changed to the stock
market he's not interested in giving you
hints on the stock market
but anything else that you'd like to
know come to split the one-ski have one
truth warn and lay your check on the
table for two therefore three million
bucks and he's there back number nine he
doesn't keep a computer on his desk but
he loves playing bridge on line in your
office do you have a computer in your
office that you it not in my office but
but other people in the office have them
so I know you're not a famous technology
person but do you have an iPad or do you
do no internet things I do internet
things yeah I love the Internet I mean
the Internet
it's fascinating to me because it's it's
probably affected my life you know
almost as much as say Bill Gates it we
have a when Bill and I appeared together
sometimes we we use the trick question
of aside from email which one of us is
on as is on the computer more and the
answer is me because you play bridge
I play bridge on the internet and every
every every night you spend yeah it's a
couple hours a night and after all these
years of doing are you a champion no no
I'm not even close I just have a good
time every you know it's the most
interesting game I've found and if
people know that they're playing with
you over the and is the name t-bone and
that's it's gotten around that I am
t-bone yeah I used to put my age is 103
so when I did something dumb people
would say for a guy hundred threes not
bad but this is my dad's desk the sat on
his desk when I was a kid when I was ten
years old I always admired no fancy
flat-screen TV just an old tube no doc
computer that means no email perhaps a
secret to Buffett success in fact number
10 he lives in a humble five bedroom
house that he bought in 1956 for thirty
one thousand five hundred dollars in
Omaha Nebraska
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so those are the 10 mind-blowing facts
about Warren Buffett I love to know
which one of the 10 was the most
surprising shocking or interesting for
you leave it down in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
this has been described as a
once-in-a-lifetime experience and you'll
understand why watch then again once you
get a taste of these particular
attention to the first spline because
that's what it's all about you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
falou
my
that's sorry
[Music]
the two of us
you
[Music]
we got each other's arm you
[Music]
story that's the glory
[Music]
one would see ones world's long media
the most important work ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be to like a little
beacon pay believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]